I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense were you a poor family growing
up yeah yeah way too deadbeat dad so
from less than I was 2 years old my mom
race is very very difficult for us but
at six years old circus is downtown LA
it was stiffer than today we had the
Bullock's tomorrow it's really cool
department stores may company with all
these Christmas things going on in front
of them you ride the little train you
see the pup with that luckiest kids in
the world
we took the streetcar down you speed a
little streetcars anyway so it's oh it's
wonderful
we thought we luckiest kids in the world
so my mom that year this would be 1950
gave my brother and I 51 a dime and said
boys each of you had little fingers you
know hold this time in half go over and
give that man ringing that the bell at
the bucket we did we put in that red
bucket we said mom why why do we give
that man at the red bucket they're a
dime in those days that's two large soda
pops and three candy bars oh god I said
mom and she said boys that's the
Salvation Army and they helped feed
people and give people places to live
that have nothing she says boys always
remember in your lives that they'll
always be people have less than you are
we could only afford a dime this year
but we're giving something and and I
would I try to volunteer a little bit
for the Red Cross to help raise money
for them but I couldn't do that alocs I
got to take care of you kids but now you
kids are participating with me with this
time and I never forgot it so even in my
writing with the Hells Angels and Satan
slave days many many years ago we're in
the Hells Angel I rode with them there
okay well you'll see when you see good
okay okay anyways but at whenever we
should have love is in Griffith Park and
I lived here in LA and I would go there
at Thanksgiving or Christmas and even
with my little son when I inherited him
also and it helps her food I just felt
good to do they just felt good today oh
it's kind of what you started do things
like that is some bread helps somebody
else out it's something that's like
getting gifts for people you know it's
really like once you start doing it you
realize how much better you feel doing
how much more fun it is instead of like
one more damn t-shirt down the street
you know and other
another another jacket no jeans it's
like to share and to see somebody light
up because of what you're doing is so
much more powerful the biggest thing
anyone could do today you I do something
different an agency reaction getting on
an elevator or an escalator turn right
around and look at the people on there
and smile good morning or good afternoon
or hi guys that's all of this turn
around again I mean you'll be amazed
often there'll be few of any people that
won't smile back and well thank you are
you having a good day too it just opens
up relationships happy you've been
described as being unstoppably positive
and I just I mean I can feel that I can
see that and you've told me how you know
you grew up in a family that you had you
know not a lot of money and you had a
deadbeat dad and your mom was obviously
a really positive influence so how do
you get to the point how do you get to
where you're at how do you think the way
you think how can you so factual eyes
how can you be positive
do you have can you identify a reason
well for me so easier than maybe for
some people because one when you're down
and out more than once you don't know
nothing and something good happens oh
boy this is great but I was with all the
respect I was born I think positive I my
mom would always tell me my god be
careful mom I'm gonna be just fine I
mean I was kind of thing for in positive
you know then obviously when you're down
you go up you get even more positive
because you're so happy and then when
you have an abundance of something and
you get to share it with people and you
see a good end result they just it's
happy if you ever you do something for
somebody else and ask absolutely nothing
in return it's the greatest high you'll
ever get now I went through the 60s okay
it's the greatest high you literature is
higher than smoking anything is that
what you how you would describe a good
giver yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the
or four people and you ask nothing in
return you do because it's the thing to
do oh you get a good hi everyone like
speaking knowledge but do it sometime
and don't tell anybody you did it
there'll be times austin especially i'll
go downtown and when I'm in LA I'll do
it cuz I was homeless here once and I'll
hand out hundred-dollar bills on some
ices from my god and I just keep on
walking and one thing they gave a stack
to was a $10,000 tax she's just the
kindest sweetest lady and I talked her a
little bit she told me a little bout her
life and I said could I give you a
couple dollars oh no no I found out a
way to make it okay cuz I don't like to
ask for any they said okay so I just
held her hand and I said can I put a
note in your pocket sure so I just put a
note in her pocket I realized you spilt
10,000 out put in her pocket there was
folded with a rubber band I said you are
so blessed won't you wait a few minutes
buried my note say a little prayer then
read the note okay and I disappeared did
you hear her scream nope they just
disappeared was he listening
[Music]